Stream.
I'm doing it right.
Oh, no.
Oh, I did it right now.
Are you ready?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
She has to find us anyway.
She has to.
How do I find you guys?
How do I look at it?
Oh, you gotta wait.
You gotta wait for it.
We're painting.
We're painting right now.
Whoa.
Hello, everybody.
I just joined.
Okay, this is not the ultimate test.
Hi.
Okay, not that big.
Hello.
Oh, God, you need someone come and paint bricks with me.
No.
Okay.
How do I how do I get out of this mood?
Help.
Okay.
I hope sounds okay.
Oh, I got an idea.
Oh, I forgot to turn on my okay.
Everything's fine.
That's all right.
Everything is fine.
Oh, man.
I had to I was recording stuff with my with my air
conditioning off And it was so hot that I have this shirt
that I got at Mooji That's just like if you sweat you won't
see it through the shirt only on one side and I sweat
through it oh my crazy how do i oh that's oh i see i don't
think my hiding spot is that good but it won't be i'll find
you i just want to give you a shot it's not it's not good i
know mine's not bad wait are we starting it not yet right no
no no we have 40 40 no that's actually four seconds get
ready get rid of it i think i'm in trouble I had an argument
with the controls, so I haven't actually painted anything.
Oh, I'm indecisive.
It's over.
Oh, that's the way I thought it was so smart, but this is a
lot harder than I expected.
Yeah, I think this is probably the only one struggling right
now.
Rotate the camera.
Oh, alt.
Wait, this is a terrible idea.
How am I going to learn how to do all this?
Oh, shoot.
It's okay.
Your job is just to shoot.
You're so, you're, you'll be fine.
Can I paint me in time?
I have seven seconds.
Before you leave the thing, yes.
If I had more time to paint because I didn't have an
argument with the controls, this would be so much fun.
Whoa, whoa.
I'm going into space.
No, no, no.
Wait, oh, shoot.
I clicked out of the game.
Wait, oh, I'm in paint mode.
Shoot.
Uh, how do I, okay.
Guys, we have more time to paint.
Keep painting, guys.
Is that somebody?
I'm painting.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What is that?
Are you just shooting things?
No, it's a little ball.
It's a little ball.
So this is my first time playing this game.
How do you play the game?
Yeah, you shoot who you think is a person.
Oh, I actually couldn't tell.
I think I just got really lucky.
Actually, sorry, Snuffy.
I didn't actually see anybody there.
Oh, who's cat calling me?
Oh, it has a mandatory cat call.
Oh, I see somebody.
Oh, yeah, we have a automatic.
Oh.
Oh, I see somebody.
Oh, my God.
You're destroying us.
I didn't even get to look at everybody.
She's too powerful.
She's the only one, and she's almost gotten home.
It's because she was sweating.
It's because I'm so sweaty.
I love yours.
I'm so sweaty.
Oh, my God.
She's stuffy.
Weddy's spaghetti.
Wait, do you come back as a new person?
No, no, no.
We're doing basic, so it's just you against the world.
How big is this, Matt?
You can't see where we were after you kill us.
as it is oh this is it oh so you're watching me walk around
oh yeah yeah yeah we're watching you walk around are my
earphones oh wait hold on let me double check that my
headphones are okay good left and right stop you guys are
hyping me up
i'm lost now hold on oh no we saw 180 seconds you're getting
hotter you're getting hotter and colder i'm getting hotter
because i'm getting older 20 times yeah you are oh wait what
is it menopause oh menopause i'm not to tell you this like
the you are next my favorite pokemon where are you you're so
lost in osaka right now i am i've never been i have nobody
to help me oh Is that a person?
Wait, you've never been to Osaka?
No, I've never been.
Wait, how many times have you been to Japan?
Don't ask.
Oh, wait.
I've been to Osaka one time.
I went to USJ.
Wait, what's...
Oh, universe.
Oh, yeah, I was going to say.
It's in universal.
Yeah.
You can climb walls.
Wait, I can.
Nobody told me this.
Oh.
Wait, how do I...
Nobody told me this.
How do I climb the walls?
I wish I knew.
I think you're just...
Wait, I don't even know where Matara is.
Wait, how do I climb the walls?
how do i climb the walls what the heck where are you oh
you're like right next to me who is the most disguised
person ever there's still two of us by the way mint there's
two of us and you have like two minutes to find us so you
have so much time i have a lot of time it's it's it's like
it's interesting because you can have the best hiding place
ever but actually are no points because they don't like the
points are based on whether or not they're looking at you
but don't perceive
Oh my god, my star.
She's never gonna find you.
Where are you?
No, no, no.
I'm on space on the wall.
Is that how you climb?
There's not much space vertically.
Oh, shoot.
I'm climbing.
Whoa.
Oh, I'm hearing whistle, baby.
I'm stuck.
Oh, wait, it's nothing.
You're dead already?
Yeah.
She was like, I got it.
Oh, I thought that you were dead.
We're living despite it all.
I know.
Oh.
I'm stuck.
Wait, give me a hint.
Nope, no hints.
Oh, wait, you're flying.
You're like, Jesus.
There's not much space.
But I mean, they could only be.
You're Jesus.
I am.
We're somewhere in Japan.
Somewhere in Japan.
We're somewhere on this map.
Like the entirety of Japan.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh, no.
I can hear the clock.
I'm in Osaka right now.
This is hard by myself.
The best place to hike is Mint's never been.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
I can't get on the top of this pole.
You did not make it good.
I see you!
I saw you!
Oh my god.
No!
This one she was practicing!
The ping!
Man, do you want to see where I was?
Yeah, where were you?
You can see it on the map.
You almost got me, but then you doubted yourself.
Oh, I see it.
Wait, where is it?
It's up top of the air conditioning.
Oh my god, I didn't know how to climb.
It was in front of your face the entire time.
Oh my god.
I can't believe she...
I did not have enough time to paint.
I think I'm stuck in the wall.
The fact that we can climb up is crazy.
I didn't know that.
Yeah, guys, the 200 frames, guys.
200 frames.
I'm playing on a potato PC.
Don't, don't.
It's like 228.
I got reflex on.
There's no way you're catching me.
Graphics are high right now.
I didn't even get to tune my graphics.
Are you using a special config to remove the shadows for
those extra frames to take my latency down by like 0.2
seconds?
Don't worry about it.
Oh, is someone talking in-game?
Who is it?
Is it me?
Oh, yeah.
I accidentally returned the title.
Hold on, sorry.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
It was the shadow button.
Oh, shadow is V in...
Oh, I see.
Yeah, when you're in paint mode.
But then V is voiced outside of paint.
You show the game screen.
So I'm going to show the password.
I know.
Hold on.
Wait, find server.
My chat's big.
mean to me doki and is saying like nobody understands your
nerd speak doki understands my nerd speak yes she does
doki's a gamer she plays the first person shooters she knows
yeah i know about the nevidea reflex and the v-sync on i
don't know what v-sync on does but i know it exists i yeah
exactly exactly you engage you engage v-sync you cap your
frame rate and then you turn on g-sync yeah exactly g-sync
Like a G-Sync.
Oh, wait.
Let me ban this guy very quickly.
Get him.
Someone is here.
Oh, you can pose?
Don't worry.
I'll also get him.
I bet it's the same guy.
Send him to the fig.
Yeah, send him to the fig.
Send him to the back rooms.
He's the back rooms.
To the back rooms.
Alright.
who hasn't oh wait who hasn't done uh seeking yet snuffy no
i haven't snuffy is the last one oh and nimi hasn't either
oh it's like i have so i don't have to do it it's actually
really fun nimi i think you like it yeah it really is it's
pretty fun oh wow look at me go i feel like i've failed oh
no you're gonna you're gonna be doing right now what are you
practicing for my dodge oh my god just do what i do and
don't care don't he's not interested in the painting she's
just gonna parkour we're on the map yeah i'm just gonna
start off you'd probably win if it was me hunting wait i'm
gonna paint myself we're gonna do this wow this is hard this
is are you guys using tablets or your mouse no okay wait oh
my gosh i can't even yeah no no no no tablets honestly the
painting is so laggy that i think even if i had a tablet it
wouldn't help like i could go try hard with my tablet, it's
in the cover.
It feels like you don't get enough time.
It's laggy as fuck.
Yeah.
I think that's the point.
The point is you're supposed to, I feel like the point is
you're supposed to keep drawing after it starts.
Oh.
Yeah.
You can refine your painting after it starts.
Or something, because I've been trying, and I just it
doesn't.
No, it doesn't.
The time a little longer.
I'll do it 150 seconds.
Oh, God.
Yeah, because I'm a new.
I'm new.
I'll add 20 more seconds to the clock.
Alright, let's do...
Let's do a...
Also, Mint, I really love your thumbnail.
Oh, thank you!
Oh my gosh!
I spent so much time on it.
Yes, thank you.
I can tell.
Where did you get your inspiration from for that?
God.
Yeah, it came to you in a dream.
Literally in a dream.
Like, I was just...
I thought for a second you were saying God, like, God, don't
even ask me, but no, you mean you got it from God.
Okay.
How do I make it?
thinner how do i make my thing stop taking her medication
and then move your mouse and now god speaks i have an idea
what to do oh i see you're terrifying that holy i couldn't
make it thinners you look like a cursed doll oh oh wow
yee-haw oh i'm hiding again yee-haw oh it's all in one room
this one might be a little rough a little scary scary scary
wait i have an Wait, I thought, Nimmy, I thought you were
going to be hunting.
Snuffy, right?
It's just me.
Oh.
No, it's just one person.
I'll do it next time.
It only picks one person, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wow.
Okay, well, no pressure, no pressure.
Just fucking laugh at mid, but now I'm feeling it.
Okay, baby.
You'll do fine.
You'll do great.
I'm going to hide within the PP of this thing.
I have no idea where to hide.
What the heck?
Oh, here.
Wait, can I did, did I do?
Wait, how do I do this?
Oh, here.
There we go.
Wait, how does it work?
Oh, no.
Yeah.
In the meantime, I'm going to draw myself how I imagine
myself.
Oh, no.
Wait, why does it say it's blue?
Wait, I'm all confused.
Okay, I give up.
That didn't take long.
Yeah, I'm going to say that was fast.
Are you talking to me?
Yeah, I'm like, okay, I give up.
Sorry.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, is it starting?
It's not starting.
no not yet we have plenty of time i'm still running around
oh space so much i still have not like so much time it's
really hard to actually like see the details when you're
painting yeah what the fuck is that this is gonna work i
think i don't think i have a great hiding spot but you know
what i haven't even found a spot yet just press space you
haven't found a spot yet you have 40 seconds one okay oh
shoot we only have i do not think i'm well hidden but you
know what yellow i'm hidden in plain sight i'm i'm so i've
got socks on if anything i have my fps to come in clutch you
really do i feel like i feel like specifically this is
really dark and the game is like no no not that dark maybe
you need to do like manual adjustments maybe that's how i
feel right Yeah.
Oh boy.
I think I'm good.
I think you're great.
I think your hiding spot is very nice mint.
You think so?
You see it?
Yeah.
If you press five and then press four, you're able to like
look around.
The color pickers slightly.
Chat.
No, that's not what I am.
Wait, I'm pressing numbers and it's not showing me anything.
What?
Okay guys.
Oh my God.
This is so cute.
Are you Renamon?
I'm thank you.
Yes I am.
Oh my God.
You are.
How fun!
I love random mine.
Thank you guys.
I needed something that made me feel like I was going to
find you guys.
I chose the wrong spot.
It's okay.
My spot is hard and then I was like, oh god, I have to
commit.
I don't have time.
Hey, I want to see you.
How do you find each other?
Yes.
Press.
You push five and then you go through with your mouse
button.
If the box is like...
Wait, five.
really scary when you don't when you can't oh i see i see oh
my game just crashed sorry no what was her spot no no don't
say it just in case she's still in the game uh i keep
getting memory issues i love seeing some people still draw
okay wait that's actually kind of good now okay okay i think
i fixed it i think wait i can't see doki hold on i think i
fixed it doki
wow i got one i didn't think it was possible you did i'm
proud of you it was a good oh she did get you i'm sorry lime
sometimes it's like you have such an obvious place but if
the hunter doesn't look there you're just lucky you know
newie i love your spot
I feel like a rage comic like clenching my fist where like
everyone's just giggling and I'm just like they're all
genuinely that's how I feel like you feel doing that that's
actually pretty good now Doki yeah yeah I think I think I
fixed it about I think yours also got really there's some
issues from certain angles like she won't look at the angle
right What was that?
Were you trying to ride the horse or were you part of it?
I was part of the statue.
Okay, from some angles it was really good, okay?
That was so cute.
I was like, is that somebody on the horse or like in the
statue itself?
Oh my god.
Where was your epic dodges?
I put against the cow I saw her double take out I was like
that's a really lumpy looking cow were those cows knocked
over before did your girls just knock them over false those
cows cows cows the cows I think they were knocked over cows
I think I was I was too scared I should have committed I
didn't know you actually saw me or not I just saw you know i
i probably would have gotten you but i was just looking you
you got too eager wait why is it your hiding spot is working
by the way oh so don't say anything wait i can't see what
you guys are dressed up as i just see dokeybird standing as
a white person oh i think you're back in the lobby movement
like the four or five everybody's just white the only one
alive like technically and everybody isn't in here anymore
because i can't actually camera take it i think it's just
matara you have to play me the first time your little butt
was so shaded it threw the whole thing off
i was hoping i didn't have it on you actually put shadows on
yeah there's shadows Wait, is that bad or good?
That's bad because your butt keeps shading.
Ah.
My eyes saw like the rump hyper fixated onto it.
My ginormous fat dumpy.
Betrayed by the cake.
Yeah, betrayed by the cake.
Not my big fatty.
Oh my gosh, I should have committed.
I should have committed to my husband's body.
Yeah, let me do the cake.
Oh boy!
Can't wait!
Shoot me!
Alright Nimi, I'll let you pick the map.
Do you want penguin hotels, sugar lad, or sewers?
The...
Sewers.
I knew it.
Alright, I'm starting...
Now.
Yippee!
Yay!
I'm gonna run out of the circle at the last minute just kind
of a or is it kind of like a big gerbil oh all right here we
go oh i gotta love those two eyes oh it's huge no vending
machines in the sewers why for food the rats are hungry
there's all the sewers in the whole world i have an idea i
have an idea too i don't have any idea I feel
overstimulated.
Here I go.
I'm going in.
Yeah, this is a little chaotic.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, my God, I can't get past this.
My idea doesn't work because it won't let me climb.
Here I go.
Is it better to do?
I'm going to get context clues by what you're saying right
now, and I'm going to find out your hiding spot.
I'm going to divine it.
No, you're not.
Oh, you're going to ask the carrots, the cards about it.
Yeah, I've already figured it out.
No, I'm just crazy.
to get to my hiding spot how do i move five of cups i know
you're near a cup oh you also know i'm an alcoholic no no
you don't we all do that we all do that it's like was that a
secret okay i'm gonna test real okay so how do i turn off
the um shadow when you're in the painting mode uh you just
press v
is there an undo button or no no not that i can see no shoot
yeah this is fine this might be good guys this is fine i
believe in you this is i'm also fine right now so fine so
fine so fine watch this wait oh wait so you press v and then
how do you know you're not shadowed do you have to like do
something oh you press v and that's oh that's our voice chat
oh gosh no that's the way in the painting yeah yeah yeah
okay make it small like you oh my god the seven seconds
count the countdown oh shoot wait i'm i'm anxious give me
more time please give me more time okay okay i'm still
painting myself we're sitting in the exam hall freaking out
please please a little bit more time yeah give me more time
give me more time coach coach coach and you see i'm trying
to get my vision in oh god guys i'm so obvious i just i
don't know i freaked out i think i'm good oh my god your
your thing is pushed uh your open mic matara you got oh
sorry oh i know where you are hello
You're still...
Uh-oh.
Hmm.
Can I go?
Are you ready?
Oh, yeah.
Ready or not?
Here I go.
Oh, yeah.
As soon as you're dropped in, you can go.
I was gonna be nice, Proctor.
Oh, that's sweet of you.
Oh.
Be nicer.
Break this off a little bit.
Oh.
Um...
I jumped!
Wait, I was supposed to be a freak every time.
Am I still on, like, open mic, by the way?
No, you're fine.
I can't actually hear the open mic even when it goes, so I
don't worry.
Okay, if you press B, it mutes open mic.
So, like, it only does accidentally do it.
Which is nice.
What the heck?
Everybody has such good...
What the heck, Lymu?
Wait, I want to see Lymu's spot.
Oh, my God.
I freaked out.
I didn't know where to put my spot.
Whoa, Doki, yours is pretty good, too.
Wait, you guys have experience.
inch man can you tell me my spot is good um hold on i'm
looking for you i'm looking for you oh you look like a
little poop my spot is good don't say that kind of stuff
oh i hear wait how do i get into free mode then i keep
pressing five and it's not working yeah it's four right wait
but it says switch to free cam and it's five sweet sweet oh
five then four that makes no sense oh wait now uh now i know
how you feel when i mispronounce words oh my god you're such
a handsome little guy you see me oh i see it though there it
is oh my god she's so handsome are updating that means
they're near oh no oh i like your outfit nimi thank you i'm
wearing my sunday best I think I need to mint earlier today
I told Nimi it's nice to e-meet her and she giggled I sure
did I'll giggle again I keep touching now what does that
mean nice to e-meet like e-meet you it's like how you write
emails to people you're like wow nice to e-meet you like
when you meet people online wow that's a good one I think
I'm really proud of my friends right now why why giggling Oh
shit, it's Hitman!
Where did Hitman go?
Wait, I lost it.
Okay, I found you.
Oh no.
Doki, you have opened my eyes in a way I didn't think was
possible.
Yeah, yeah.
What does that mean?
All those clips on my algorithm paid off.
Yeah.
Yeah, like yours is crazy.
Miss me, I'm whistling, I'm whistling.
Woo, woo, woo.
Are you beyond the wall?
Maybe.
Wow, that's hard.
Woo-hoo.
You are never fine.
Actually, don't you like scoot over like a little bit.
No.
Just like scoot over like one bit.
I promise you, it'll really help.
I know I'm really serious.
If I scoot, I'm gonna fall.
What do you mean you'll fall?
I'm gonna fall.
She's not even here.
Come on, come on, just do it.
Come on, just do it.
Not even here.
sabotage going on here come on do it just do it she is
literally she's literally next to me no she's literally yes
she is don't i literally see it she is i wish you got points
for taunting no she's actually so far she is so close she's
looking at me okay i'm taunting her away i'm taunting her
she's like okay now move do it dokey you have no balls come
on her eyes do it come on Come on!
No!
The humiliation!
This level is so hard.
Everybody has such good spots.
Yeah, this level is pain.
I know, I can't believe that I was found so easily.
Thank you.
I wanted her to have a win, so I jumped in the air.
It's my only win.
Honestly, everybody's just really hard in this one.
I mean, I don't think anybody could do this by themselves.
yeah this one is like loaded no i don't think even if we had
infection would would mint be much of a help would come on
dokey you could have had it be like really good looking come
on come on oh my gosh neemie come here look up wait yeah i
need to experience this can i go to free cam Nimi look up
yeah just look up just look up do you see it oh hey on hey
on hey on this is why you should move where's everybody else
can i not go to free cam and look in the wall that's crazy i
was behind a little box had the little restaurant is also
crazy oh where am i wait where was lime even lime was like
blended with the wall like actual like pita in the games it
was kind of crazy
what would infection do it means that if you get shot you
help to hunt I think wouldn't that be a cheat because then
you see where everybody else is you don't get to see where
everybody is you don't see I would say that Mimi didn't see
you guys but I can glaze myself a bit she literally like
started walking on top of me yeah I watched that I don't
know if I even saw you in the in the end I was like in this
room I was like on top of the tanker oh my gosh you were
just like looking for so long I'm proud I'm proud of myself
I can't look at that from first games of this game the
character development all right we're doing penguin hotel
and then oh I'll be the hunter you want to hunt all right
here go snobster I did infection catch some wonder hunters
oh okay okay i'm recruiting people to my cause oh i sure
hope you don't catch me it'd be terrible if i had to come
and hunt with you oh i just hate wow okay wait this penguin
room that is crazy hmm so we don't get to see anybody else
yeah yeah oh we can't oh that's so because otherwise you
could like when you die you just go to all the hiding spots
you already saw okay wait wait wait wait i have no idea what
time wait i figured it out i have no idea where i'm going
i'm scared i feel lonely yes i feel there you go no one will
find me like this no one will find me on me i kind of want
to be found you know what snuffy If you don't find me,
that's on you.
That's okay.
Oh, God.
Okay, time to paint.
Okay, me too.
I'm going to be the most round.
Oh, yeah.
The most rotund?
Yeah.
Oh, that's a hint right there.
That's a hint.
It is.
That is a hint.
Aren't we, like, penguin?
Are we penguins?
Or are we dancers?
Are we human?
What the fuck?
Dancing queen.
Oh, my game.
Okay, wait.
It's not letting me, like, pick my body thingy.
Uh-oh.
It's not letting me, like...
Wait.
I can do this.
It's not letting you pick what?
Like, how I want to...
Your nose?
Be.
No, my...
I heard it's not letting me pick my booty hole, so I have no
idea what you're doing.
Oh, sorry.
That was me talking about my booty hole.
Okay.
like it's not letting me pick um how i want to be my body to
be for some reason it's like giving me problem with it
that's weird i'm scared okay i found it i had so much faith
in my ability oh she late i gotta keep going oh my okay oh
oh okay it's fine nothing happened i believe you you guys
noises no everything's fine it's a very serious map oh yeah
uh okay we gotta catch them all guys oh guys this is not
looking good for me me neither girls smell i'm feeling good
do you not smell girls are these penguins these are not
penguins Wait, why are there robots and penguins?
Is this like a Mario reference?
Big pen.
Wait, how do you- Pen 15 ink!
I'm trying to zoom out and it won't let me.
I'm trying to.
The game is a little buggy, I think it is.
Free cam?
Am I actually in free cam?
Yeah.
There we go.
Whoa!
Whoa.
Sounds like there might be- Are you Ash Ketchum?
I am!
I'm camping!
them all oh is that what you're doing every time like you
want you just like sit there and paint yourself while you're
waiting for us that's cute digimon and then pokemon is a
little controversial no whoa someone could like i might have
picked one first over the other this is hard if you guys are
in this room say i i oh oh i guess there's only one person
in that room oh it's i it's the whole place of room or the
one room you just you just i want to be included Wait, she's
gonna catch them all!
She's gonna catch them all!
Catch them, catch them, catch them!
You guys are so slow on the page.
Catch them all!
Gotta catch them all!
This is hard.
This is so much harder than the last time.
Snuffy, I swear you'll be able to find me.
There's, don't, you're gonna, what happens if I don't, huh?
Then everybody's gonna tell me that I'm a failure.
Oh!
What?
I accidentally moved!
Oh, uh-oh.
What happened?
Oh my god.
We stopped.
I accidentally moved.
Oh, we can't see each other where someone is.
Did you find me?
I accidentally moved.
I don't see anybody.
Wow, there's like so many rooms in here.
You guys, you're all like, oh, this is gonna be so easy.
No, I'm not gonna find that single person.
that was me whistling at one point you know somebody's like
i'm gonna catch them all wait no let me catch one oh nice
i've got did you like my spot yeah that oh my gosh if i
didn't second guys that would have been like good painting
the wallpaper this makes me think like um that our hiding
spots are actually pretty good is just when you know we're
people are you're like oh obviously you're here you know but
when you're actually searching for it you're like wait a
second this is rough have some guys please be gentle with me
I accidentally moved is your pattern like gonna be horribly
off center and like i don't know i really don't know oh my
god there's two of them they're multiplying you're
multiplying this is the longest min has stayed alive i know
hello everybody in this room i'm now in this okay sweating
wasn't bullying enough You might have, someone might have
just passed Matara.
Uh-oh.
She just got 14 points somewhere.
Okay.
What the hell is wrong with you?
Go back to bullying mid.
That's very suspicious about all of these.
It's over.
I don't want to see.
I mean, technically you could just spam your bullet, right?
Can we see each other though?
Like at the moment, like in free cam too?
No.
Because then if you go on the other team, it's going to.
You're gonna know where they are.
Oh, that's fair.
Yeah.
Oh, one shot, one kill.
This is hard.
I don't even know where you girls are.
Hold on.
Let me try to see.
No, I don't know where anyone is.
I don't think you can see when even, like, your free cam,
right?
Yeah.
I no longer want to be the hunter, you guys.
I take it.
No!
I'll be the hunter next time.
It's fun.
Hunter is stressful.
Where are you guys?
Where are you?
I was trying to build gingerbread bodies.
How am I, how are you not, how is this even possible?
is rough I kind of want us to do it again with infection
yeah longer seeking time maybe longer I feel like the only
like three or four whistles actually go off before it ends
yeah yeah I have to my chat was doubting my spot so was mine
they did not believe all right snappy turn around Lymu come
back to where you hid.
Lymu come back to where you, yeah where you were.
What the hell, that's so good.
Your spot.
What?
Very good.
Dang it.
Wait, where was Nimi?
Too powerful.
Yeah, where's Nimi?
I'm in the plush in this room.
Oh, that's so good!
Wait, what?
Oh, I want to see.
Nimi's so powerful.
Yeah, there's something.
Mimi was really good.
I was hard.
I'm gonna cry.
That map was really tough.
I was.
I'm gonna be a high level.
Like if I don't find her then everybody's gonna laugh at me
and I'm never gonna live it down ever.
So that's now I was gonna be on my gravestone.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
You're like associate every time.
It's like you think you forget about it and then like 20
years later you're gonna remember it and you just have like
little memory to come back in 20 years.
to me i couldn't i won't be able to ever find anything i
will never be able to locate something nobody i wouldn't
either you know where your keys are wait no you're that girl
who couldn't find mindo in that one sorry i was just even i
even drew my butthole like i'm surprised
the butt was really good i was able to draw all of that
within this it would have been the second she was given i
was crazy did you draw while they were hot while they were
seeking me yeah neemie i did i was drawing the whole oh yeah
i wanted to see someone send it to me no way you could have
finished that in like the time we had i was still working on
it up until the end yeah yeah that's kind of like what i do
i just like sit there and paint the whole time yeah i'll add
search i'll add 20 more seconds to search time maybe shorten
the time between whistles too okay i'll put 35 seconds it's
because when when the rooms are small the whistles going off
as often as they did felt like such a cheap but when the
rooms are big you kind of need the whistles to go off more I
put 25 more seconds and search time alright and then we're
doing sugar then and now we can download um extra maps after
that because I want to do the Minecraft I want to do the
Minecraft oh there's a Minecraft oh please please Please I
want to do Minecraft.
Please.
I want to play Minecraft.
Un cola.
Oh shit, okay, I fucked up three times, guys.
I actually reset them.
50 seconds!
Rush game, rush game, rush game!
Fast game, fast game!
I'll give you more time once I start.
Oh, that's sweet.
Thank you.
Yeah, I messed up there.
Oops.
miffy yeah i'm i'm doing i'm doing a good round fun round
very good wait i let's see how do i oh this is gonna be hard
wait what if oh no oh no i'm i'm thinking right now you
better be i'm still thinking right now the outward thought
process We're doing infection, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
I picked a boring spot this time.
I picked a really stupid spot.
Oh, I messed up my face, so please don't look at it.
Wait, actually, the game is only letting me walk backwards.
Oh, I'm in paint mode.
Okay, I'm good.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la.
Someone's gonna be in these stripes, I know it.
Whistle if you're in the stripes.
Oh Oh, I messed up
Did you like it?
I did like it.
I almost didn't see it.
I was I almost didn't see it.
Oh It was funny when I saw him it was like 50 seconds.
Oh, never mind man.
Never mind Gamers don't look up guys.
I Don't think I'm hiding as well as I could be wait why is
this blinking wait why was it blinking where'd you go I see
it if they're blinking that means they're cheating oh you
freaking cheater you freaking cheater girls I think I can
hide a little better Matara's always hiding under who's left
sneaky like that
I'm a cockroach.
It makes you feel good.
It's true.
I'm trying to hide in plain sight.
She has to sneak her in.
I like when I'm sleeping to put my blanket all over my face.
Oh, I can't think of a nightmare level for me.
I really didn't hide well.
I promise, like, I have a big problem with my hiding spot.
Oh, please be gentle.
Someone there.
Please be gentle.
Someone's near here.
saying that i think you're just saying that oh i know the
whistle on your team man no i'm talking about mataro oh my
god oh when you do find me can you show the others where i'm
at just because i'm curious you just want us to give you
more points yeah i mean i'll come find you but then i'm
gonna look away so that you don't get points i mean i'm not
playing for points i'm playing for embarrassment
guys know that I'm there she's like like emotionally for us
it sounded close to me too though the freaking whistle is so
hard the whistles kind of shit oh oh I just oh I just shot
your ass wait wait wait Matara show us show us she was she
was a tree up here like I was a Christmas tree oh my gosh so
I was floating in the air she was a she was a Chris Chris
was tree here i i kind of like went up and i jump scared
myself with the humanoid and just shot you yeah yeah
remember when i when i let you win at the beginning i'll
wait no wait so who's left you let me win didn't i refuse to
shoot you at the very beginning you stood up and i didn't
shoot you oh i see i see all right it's time to find nimi
chocolate are you i'm a little sweet treat you are a little
sweet treat
where is me me me me me give us a little have you guys the
clouds by the way the cloud oh no i haven't wait can you get
up there i looked at them but i don't know if i can get all
the way up
Mimi.
Oh!
Where was she?
She was right here, right here on me.
I knew she was the right- oh, that is good.
Look at this.
Wait, where we're at?
That's so good.
Oh, wow, that is good.
That is good.
You did really well.
Thank you.
It's hot.
You get a little thumbs up.
Yeah, I give you a thumbs up.
Oh my gosh, I only found it because I looked here and I was
like, that looks like a, that does not look right.
Dude, for 50 second hiding plus infection, that was pretty
good.
Yeah.
It's a boring spot though.
Don't forget to adjust the painting time.
This time around.
I knew somebody was a little stripe.
I knew it.
Yeah, I was.
When you said that.
That's, that's my ocean.
I was home.
Do we want to try the hotel again with, uh, yeah.
sure whatever you guys want yeah with more time for hotel
okay oh was that the penguin one yeah the penguin hotel yeah
yeah penguin hotel 120 wait time search time 325 and then 35
i don't mind trying to be hunter if you guys already go for
it i have no respect i don't want to be the hunter either
please please don't hide too well i beg you please don't
worry there's it's infection so you'll have i just find one
person yeah yeah yeah i find it'll not even time to find me
too now we know what your spot is i have to redeem myself in
this one you do you do the next that we hang out i will
redeem myself wait oh my gosh wait can i get to this i start
stuttering ask you what i feel about it's never gonna be
nobody we better be oh no my lee okay i have it just be my
lee the next time we hang out i will redeem myself Oh shoot,
no, it's blinking.
Why is it blinking all of a sudden?
No, no.
You're cheating.
I'm not trying to.
That's what they all say.
Yeah.
Let me do this.
Ladies, no pressure, but I'm coming.
Oh, wait, already?
Yeah.
Wait, no, no.
A minute.
No, no, no.
I'm coming right now.
I'm already looking for you.
Dang it.
I don't, I don't think so.
already here i'm looking at you i'll make this one i don't
believe you i'll make this work i promise you i'm gonna make
i'm gonna make this work too i'm gonna make it work i'm
gonna make it work this looks so easy i don't think i'm
pulling it off oh you got this i'm gonna make it work i'm
gonna make it work oh okay okay i'm so ready it's gotta work
guys it's gotta work it's gotta work all Ready or not, here
I come.
I'm not.
I'm already here.
I'm already.
Wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh gosh.
I'm lagging.
Oh, God.
All right, girls.
I've been searching for a while, but now I'm finally here.
Yeah.
Aw.
Oh, my God.
There's rooms I've never even seen before.
Yeah.
Wow.
maybe yeah why are you laughing you know how like when you
swap perspective and you think it's so good what's written
on my back why did you write my name on your back you freak
honestly i was like oh that's gonna be kind of like a shit
move if i find her but i didn't even know it was you I
literally was just like what's written on my bag, but then I
remember that you are very likely to do that.
I was, I was trying to make it work, but it would tell me
every time I scooted in the toilet that I was too hidden.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that is good.
Yeah, I was trying to be a little.
Are you pooped on my back?
I pooped on my back.
Wait, why did Vittar go straight to the toilet?
Oh, you found her too.
Honestly, I don't even know.
Oh, I don't know if there's anyone else in here.
I came back.
I'm just going through rooms I didn't see before.
But to be honest, she, like, stood out in the toilet fully.
Like, she was not hidden.
Wait, how do I get up?
Oh, that's me, yeah.
I'm not.
I was being a little shit in the toilet.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I'm also not really looking around.
Wait, how do I go?
This one's really, like, hard.
I feel like there's lots of, like, all the balloons are such
a weird shape, and the place is really big.
Yeah.
Oh, somebody whistled.
This really shouldn't work at all, like at all.
Am I stuck in the stairs, you guys?
Oh, are you?
A little bit.
Am I?
No, you're good.
You're good.
You're great.
Oh, okay.
But it wouldn't let me move.
Going back to my hiding spot from before.
Hmm.
Oh my God, your steps are actually like, oh, they're making
me think maybe it's somebody else's.
Oh.
Hmm.
I'm stuck.
I know previously Doki had a really good hiding spot with
the balloons.
Where was she?
Which balloon was she?
She was on the ceiling over here by the exit.
Oh, good.
She would look up.
That leaves Mimi and Snuffy.
Yeah, Doki, you always hide up.
Yeah, you always hide because gamers don't look up.
Yeah.
I would look up.
I would, of course, would look up.
Oh.
Someone's in here.
Someone's in here, yeah.
Someone's in where?
It's hard to tell because they could be upstairs and it
would still like sound like that, no?
I don't know.
Snuffy.
Can you see anybody using my hiding spot from before?
No, no.
I'm comfy where I am.
I'm comfy.
are you comfy here happy is that that is that a hint right
there kind of oh she might be near a couch or a bed do you
think i would find a couch comfortable oh see i hear it in
here right oh are you hearing it too liable i don't know i
can never actually tell where the whistles are coming from
yeah it's like in this room or the room next door to us i
feel like because they all play it once my brain just goes
what the fuck i know me too passed by neemie because uh her
her score went up where do you see her score yeah i'm
metagaming right now where do you see her score this is how
this justifies this justifies my hunter game is it six oh my
god wait are you kidding me i had no idea you could see the
scores this whole time oh she's near us somewhere oh my god
neemie's getting good at this game i know she's drawing
textures now she's still drawing are you still drawing yes
actually i'm not this time not this time i'm not as creative
this time i feel like it's around here it's not a creative
one you're always creative oh oh tell me where you are oh
okay anyway yeah everybody she's an artist artist Oh my god,
you girls are good.
I'm just saying.
I'm curious where Snuffy is.
This is Snuffy's revenge.
Snuffy, give us a hint.
Absolutely no, I hope you all perish.
I don't know.
My spot is so easy.
Mine was easy.
It's super simple.
I'm sorry, you're blind.
Toxic mecha chameleon player.
That's where she was.
I have no idea.
I'm so excited to see where you girls were.
Good job.
I was really good.
Where are you guys?
Oh my god.
My neighbors never look up.
I've had so many times.
Where's Nevy?
Oh my god.
I never even saw this room.
I had no idea.
I knew you were in here!
I knew it!
Goddamn gamers never looked up!
I looked up for that, but not for...
I looked up.
I didn't fucking see her though.
Oh my god.
Those were some insane hiding spots.
Let me count on the Minecraft map, guys.
Yippee!
Wait, Nimi, I was trying to see...
Where did you end up hiding?
I was in the armpit.
Nimi was inside the armpit of one of the penguins.
Can we do not infection so that we can see where each other
are?
That's more fun.
Yeah, I agree.
Even though it's fun to have teamwork, I like seeing
everybody's videos.
I mean, if Minecraft is too big, then it's understandable,
but...
Alright, let me see if I can find nothing's too big for the
power of friendship.
Oh, where is it?
It is in workshop.
Yeah, we could always do two hunters now that we have six of
us.
Oh, there's so many minecraft maps oh my god there's team
fortune oh my god there's digital circus i am disguising
myself as jacks no i would be jacks maybe do like maybe do
no infection and two hunters or something yeah we can do
that i'm gonna be subscribing real quick to minecraft i'll
subscribe to several minecraft ones there's a minecraft
lobby you found hold on i think my computer is crashing hold
on Oh, give me a second.
I'm going to grab the sparkling water.
Oh, please, please.
Is there a Garfield one?
There is no Garfield one.
Where would you even be in like the comic?
I'm hiding in the lasagna.
It's all a lasagna.
Yeah, I imagine.
I'm subscribing to Peaches Castle.
Okay.
Oh, that's a good one.
Oh, there's SpongeBob.
There's Bikini Bottom.
all right i subscribe the bikini bottom what else is there
there's luigi's mansion i'll grab luigi's mansion sounds
really fun actually that sounds cute let's see oh there's cs
there's canisteri there's the peak airport my chat brings up
a good question if it's like in the settings i'm not sure if
it is but can we can we increase like the end game time so
we can have see everybody's spikes yeah oh yeah i'll
increase that terrifying where is the where are you also
jacks wait i don't even i couldn't remember what he looked
like no i think that's jacks that's jacks i look like a
cowardly die you do like a spiral there's finnaf wait i'll
download the finnaf one wait do we also have to download the
map we do once once it's picked oh yeah we like you know
when you join like a like a gary's mod server or like ttt or
something yeah no i don't know or a left for dead server
ladies oh there's the lush caves too i'll grab that.
Pick something.
Do you have two?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just downloading lots of maps right now for us.
There's Genshin Impact.
I don't know.
Genshin Impact.
Send me to Minecraft right now!
Um, can you be a little bit patient?
I'm in, uh, Matara's peeing right now, so we have plenty of
time.
Oh, that's right.
No, I'm Jack's from the Amazing Digital Circus and he will
listen to me right now.
hi we're doing some like we're doing some you know modern
art we're expressing ourselves I thought we were hugging we
can do that too it's like we're hugging if you're like
you're you know not as into the friendship as I am I guess
this is the kind of thing yeah there we go that looks cute
that does look cute All right, I got, I got, there's an
Overwatch, there's Li-Zhong Tower.
Whoa, wait, Overwatch?
Do Overwatch.
There's a Li-Zhong Tower.
Okay, wait, wait.
I want to go to Li-Zhong Tower.
Wait, wait, is there Hanamura?
Can we bring back Hanamura in this game?
Because all of you guys are jacks, we might as well do
digital stuff.
Hold on, I'm becoming POMNI right now.
Hold on.
I'm becoming POMNI.
Beautiful women.
Okay, uh, answer check that out to you.
60 seconds for answer check down mm-hmm are we all back I'm
so excited yeah sorry for the delay digital circus first I
don't know what it looks like it didn't have a preview image
so we're gonna see what it looks like can you guys give me a
TLDR of digital circus click here to download it but like no
spoiler I'm downloading downloading oh you like subscribe to
it like in left for dead
i'm gonna leave you for dead oh god wait does that say i
need to download it still yes yeah you need to click you
need to click it as well oh i am i am okay i forgot to do
the two hunters thing so we're 100 infection for this oh man
it's at 98 spots no spots i don't want to be a hunter oh why
did the why did the why is this weird right now why is this
ceiling come down for you guys yeah it did we're so you mean
he's still up there i have no idea what this looks like oh
my god this is huge wait i'm still on the ground oh it won't
let me leave it out of the ground it's too big here wait
wait what are we oh gosh my game is glitching like crazy you
guys but i'm not we still we still only have one hunter I'm
still in oh okay okay wait do we get to go to the the circus
help are you guys are you guys stuck by the only person that
got out I got out I'm hiding I got out it's so big it's
gonna take me 80 seconds to run to the other side this map
is really big I can't realize how big this map is oh god oh
oh I'm free I'm free I'm free you know what I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna wing it I don't I don't think materially have
time to find anybody.
It's me.
It's the end.
It's gonna be me.
It's gonna be a kid.
If you can't find me.
If you go here.
You deserve to kill me.
Wait, there's an invisible wall.
The craziest map I've ever seen.
There's an invisible wall on some of the stuff.
I walked all the way over here to some of the fence.
Me too.
I'm gonna cry.
My amazing- You guys are stressing me out.
Please just hide in the game.
Please don't talk.
I'm a tiger.
You're open mic again.
If you find me, you deserve to kill me.
I'll just say that.
This is diabolical.
I'm sorry.
There's just no way.
I'm POMNI.
You're POMNI?
Yep.
Oh, shoot.
I hope so.
I'm doing this with no reference, by the way.
So I don't know what he actually looks like.
I'm POMNI.
I got kind of intimidated by the size of the map and kind of
just like meandered.
And then panicked.
Oh shoot, I colored!
Okay, wait.
Oh, I'm stuck at the floor!
What the hell?
Oh no, yeah, yeah, we all got stuck.
You kind of have to like jump out.
Wow, we...
Oh.
I think it's gonna take you at least a minute to walk where
I am.
Yeah.
You deserve to go.
Wait, I can hear Matara, I think.
Can you?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, I hear somebody else now.
I'm at your feet.
You are.
I know it's not me.
Okay, I'm muted.
Oh, it's infection.
Doki, are you all the way in the top of the pole?
I miss you guys.
I wish I could see you.
I feel so isolated in the moment.
If you come all the way up here, you deserve to kiss.
I can't even see.
I think this map might be a little big.
You are able to walk all the way over to the other side,
which I'm definitely am not.
Oh, wait.
I'm definitely at the far side of the map and you should
walk all the way over there, yeah.
Yeah, I'm going to I'm going to come help you.
I'm going to come help you.
Oh, I just dropped.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Can I move?
Hold on.
How do I move?
Amazingly fucking gigantic circus.
Wait, I'm loading and I don't know why.
Wait, can anybody see me?
flying in the air yes and i can't i can't run anymore you
you're fucking like you're styling in the air you're what's
happening to me yeah you're flying for some reason i can't
get out i'm trying to get out to help min but don't kill me
look where i am i'm trying i'm where i am though i can't
look where you are it's infection oh oh my god why is there
like a where would you go if you hit control can you get
back down oh that was i don't know i'm stuck in the air my
mean to if you if i hit what i'll get unstuck i think this
map is kind of amazing yeah i think this map might be made
for bigger expect bin to start freaking flying
i can't help it guys i'm trying to move so i can okay i'm
coming to you i'm here i'm landed perfectly you're never
gonna find me i'm here are you jacks are you jacks so
there's probably i've been perfectly with the theme okay
good He is floating down too.
Wait, I see it.
Wait, who is that?
Oh, it's so cute.
Maybe the map is so big that you just start going.
Is that somebody?
Okay, so she's right below me.
It's like an airplane strip.
Wait, Stephanie, come back here.
She's right below me.
Wait, who is this?
Wait, do you understand how long it's going to take me to
walk all the way over the head?
Wait, how do I...
Wait, there's somebody on the couch.
Help me, help me.
It's amazing digital jacks I can't see you!
Get out of the air!
Steffy's shooter!
This is literally just like the show.
Wait, is there somebody actually on the couch?
Because I can't see them.
This map is fucked.
Oh wait, you can't- No, there is somebody on the couch.
Oh, maybe there's multiple couches.
Where Snuffy is!
Yeah, no, I can't see anybody on that couch.
We should be- Shooters, Steffy!
Oh yeah, maybe because, yeah, maybe because I'm still
hidden.
Yeah, that's why.
That's why.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Where are you with all?
I'm right here.
Where's my place?
Why are you so tiny?
Why?
Hello.
You're one of the people.
You're not a hunter.
Why are you so small?
I can't.
This is harder than looking on the map.
I can't shoot you.
You're too tiny.
I can't get you.
I can't get you out.
I'm sorry.
I'm making it.
I'm gonna sort of sit down in this tree.
Talk about it.
Because I can't see her, you just don't look like you're
having a fucking episode.
You're just shooting nothing.
Wait, so Limu, you could see the couch from where you are.
No, I was watching you guys.
I can see the couch from here.
Like, I can see you guys.
I can spectate you, but I can't spectate the hiders or see
them.
Why is there areas that are completely dark?
I don't know if this is a very good map.
Can we have a hint?
Can you have a hint?
sky so good luck i'm in the digits my circus now i think i'm
stuck oh my god i'm stuck i can't i can't get up jackson
town i'm stuck i'm trying to lure you guys over a bit and
nibbler you can't be staying in these things what the fuck
is the nibbler you don't remember i cried when he abstracted
me too me too oh wait what episode what did he abstracted
literally the pilot oh spoiler you have to you have to hit
an episode the yeah for true fans here one yeah the pure one
supported but there was a i think i know clips yeah i just i
know crazy i'm in the i'm in the bathroom oh my god all
right where were you i did not wait to see this i see the
tiny thing glowing i can't even i can't there's no way i can
find that you're
you limo she's right here right below me i'm literally oh my
god i can't find you you're literally an aunt to me your
aunt to me it would have been slightly easier to find me if
you know you hadn't ended up in the sky box i don't know i
can now i ended up in a place where i'm like i'm like
floating but also laying down oh my god palm me i'm palm me
yeah and then mrs floated up Walked towards me in this
fucking sky I figured out I'm flying too now I finally
figured it out Wait how did you do it?
The amazing digital flying machine Dang Damn that's how she
did it Alright now okay now let me adjust everything Don't
go I don't want to go back there please Minecraft map
Alright we'll do Minecraft now Yippur I like the Minecraft
Alright let me know whenever you guys are ready and i'll how
do we know how big the map is though can you do you have any
like idea i have no idea i saw people do the minecraft one
on twitter so it must be good so you're gonna yeah you've
been training you've been pre-training i haven't stolen a
single hiding spot yet i don't think all right maybe the
balloon i'm readying up i'm starting you guys got down there
ready subscribing subscribing oh subscribing oh sorry the
error was processing wait oh you've made too many requests
me too oh oh i didn't get that i'll try again yeah me too no
way we chose because you chose the digital circuits first
wait wait let's search it let's search it uh what was it in
the it was just minecraft Minecraft.
It's just Minecraft.
It's just Minecraft lobby UPG?
Keep refreshing.
It's just called Minecraft.
Oh, I got it.
Nice, nice.
Okay, I'm coming.
Oh, amazing.
I'm subscribing.
Don't forget to like and subscribe, everyone.
Click the bell button if you want to get notifications.
Click the link in the description.
check out our merch guys i hope i'm rich can we go to like a
restaurant place or something oh that's such a great idea i
want to be a diner oh yeah yeah nice
do you think they would have a pokemon map or a digimon did
you get the right map because it says you still haven't done
yeah oh oh there it goes yeah yeah it was just taking a
little while oh i see i see we should see if someone
uploaded the place the the fucking sim restaurant on from
when we did the sloppy sisters i'm noticing everybody has
likes above their head but me uh-huh i can give you a like
don't don't do it don't give her like no uh oh snuffy and i
dream team hunters oh that's what's going on i was like did
we mess up okay put on your put on your uh scariest hunting
outfit put on your hunting shoes this is gonna be wait is
this gonna be really hard because we have round brushes and
everything here is square No.
Like, all of the actual pixels, it's all square.
No?
No.
Oh, like the Minecraft.
No, no.
I am mistaken, clearly.
Who's the hunter?
All circles are squares.
Me and you're just round.
Oh, too.
Yeah, I'm in.
And I'm not going to give you a like.
Okay.
Damn.
I'm not begging for likes at all.
I'm never.
God.
okay i'm painting i'm painting me too we're all locked in
yeah we are we're all we're all serious gamers now minecraft
is very serious i like the minecraft i am steve chicken
jockey oh i still haven't you guys know that one dude your
references are out of control are you i still haven't chance
of watching the movie i've not watched the movie you haven't
watched the movie oh shoot not yet i mean it took me like
years to actually play minecraft so i figure i got plenty of
time to actually watch the movie yeah oh my god forgot about
this i forgot about painting my booty oh my god
excited all right ladies one at a time oh stop this is so
cute okay stop wait this is actually the cutest thing ever
oh how do i be giggling huh why be giggling what's going on
this is so i just looked at myself from a different angle
just read it i wouldn't have been able to figure out
god this is so cute oh oh this map isn't that big well it's
got it's got a lot going on though i can't tell if you miss
hmm all right let's see if i can find the others
oh oh wait we're back in regular mode yeah yeah yeah so we
can oh yeah it's solely up to us wait how do i get back to
me wait oh there i am can you open the chest and she's just
hiding in the chest imagine wait who's here that was good
though that was good we almost got it what the fuck is what
the fuck are you?
you're a sponge bob?
you're a sponge bob I'm playing everybody on this game right
here what the heck
ladies maybe oh nimi just got so many points what happened i
can't wait i'm dead already oh what the fuck is your spot i
know like it okay wow oh wow we all technically had the same
idea but i know yeah i have no idea where you would even
hide on this map dbh so small Mimi was really tiny when I
found her so they're gonna be tiny yeah I was in the fire oh
oh it doesn't move okay I hear somebody clues but I don't
know how close I don't even I don't hear anybody I heard a
whistle at my point in the mop wait oh yeah we did oh hey
didn't we I don't know if right now all the points happen
here Oh no.
Oh no.
Oh dear.
Okay, they're back over there.
Chicken jockey.
Isla J can't see anybody.
This is crazy.
Chicken.
Ooh, steers.
I'm a chicken.
this is so difficult i love it i just need to find one of
you i feel like i'm straighting my eyes the sky is so
freaking yeah i'm like yeah it's like that's the brightness
it's very bright yeah i like your i like your hiding spot
too me it's very good thank you that applies to all of us
Uh-huh.
No.
Yeah, ruin your own game.
Sevortage yourself.
Fuck off.
Well, if I give my head and it's applied to all of you guys
because we all have the same idea.
We all have the same idea.
Well, if you find one, then it gives you a hint for
everybody else.
Oh, that's true.
Okay.
You find one of us.
You might find one of us.
You find all of us.
I've been like, some of us are like right by Dokey and we
have no idea.
idea yeah you've run by doki like a million times how did
you find one of us you'll find it to me how did you you
found both of them so I have no idea what to look for
they're just hiding in these little like what do they call
it in video game debris where it's just no in flat planes
together so they're just because you only found it because
you i blocked your path isn't it you were just no i
literally looked down because i've already looked all the
ups so i mean what do you want you have not looked all the
ups you have not looked at all the ups every single ups has
been looked at all the ups you have not looked all the ups
that is a crazy map this is awesome i don't think you would
have stopped me i don't know if that's a thing i think i
would have just walked over you don't know if the hiders
have collision yeah i think i was like looking on roofs and
stuff i don't even know where i oh there i am did you guys
yeah okay i'm waiting to see i'm gonna give mint an up boat
yeah yeah man you get an up dude now wow oh that was really
good too nimi yours is great wait i want to see nimi oh wait
i told you oh nimi's is so good oh that's the the savings we
did we all got in an intersection yeah nobody where did
limes wait where's yours i'm in the tree limes isn't
possible he walked around my tree at one point oh my god oh
my god that's crazy was like nobody up here yeah honestly i
couldn't see shit that's awesome what a great go have go
have a look i smooshed myself yeah yeah i want to see i want
to see yeah it's really good tree i can't find you wait how
does this not is like getting yourself my fear that's what I
was thinking I don't know it doesn't get mad at you if you
like blend it does I think it doesn't yell at me so yeah I
think is it the mod I'm not giving you that was hard that
was freaking that was really fun yeah you weren't getting up
to it from me there all right you guys want to do bikini
bottom or the diner oh the diner the diner yeah the crabby
patty all right let me find it
i'm so good all right phase two hunters still two hunters oh
i want to be a hunter i want to kill i haven't been a hunter
in a while i'll hunt do you guys have time to go do hunting
I think actually I don't know nobody went on there so I
think it's true random now wait I can't okay I can't get
yeah true random oh let the chips fall where they may okay
oh wait you can move you can move oh wait yeah everyone
jumps out so it's still random
is me i got this i got this wait oh my gosh oh my gosh let
me rescue crap pizza is the pizza what accent was that big
sausage pizza i can see the digital circus from here i
actually can this is best of who is this guy haunted by the
digital circus forever oh why are you painting actually the
diner's pretty small and the hiding places are not are not
who is this guy who's this guy standing here what is this
that's weird i don't like that i don't like that either that
freaks me out um this this is not ideal no no no do not like
this diner is uh wait there's just guys in here ew and
there's poop on the floor this place is disgusting it's
actually quite a nasty diner yeah yeah wait
so sure about this one i actually genuinely cannot find a
place to hide we're gonna win this yeah you girls are you
girls are legit gonna win this this is actually kind of
tough yeah
we're about to do some diners drive-ins and jives yeah i
don't know if he has a catchphrase and i'm guy feary i'm guy
feary that's his catchphrase just says the name Yeah, I'm
scary.
Matara, look where I'm at.
I see, I see.
I just don't know where to go.
Join me, join me, join me, join me.
17 seconds.
No.
I actually, I don't know.
I think I could have gone up.
Two flavor towns.
Yeah, the hiding spots suck.
Yeah, I see you, Lymo.
Yep, yep.
Sorry.
All right, here we come.
All right, that's a speed run stuffy.
B-p-p-p-p-p.
Yeah.
We're ready.
Okay.
Yeah, this is going to be a quick one.
I'm about to blow this stand.
I was a guy.
What is this?
Is this a guy or is this you guys?
Is this like a fake person?
Just like to throw me off?
Nimmy, are you okay?
Try shooting it.
That's a fake person.
Wait, that's a fake.
Oh, I thought that was a real one.
I was like, who's that over there?
just to throw us off how small do you think they are well
they can't be that oh no that's a fake person too that's a
fake person too no you'll see the hiding spots suck yeah
unless there's a secret section of the fake person I don't
know man
I think we're all in the bathroom.
The bathroom was the only place to hide.
It was.
What about the person at the sink?
I don't think this one needed two hunters.
This is so small.
I mean, I found everybody.
What do you mean?
I found...
Let's go.
This is what you guys were.
Yeah, there was like nothing to hide in or against.
No, man.
I did all this Guy Fury art for nothing.
I don't think he's gonna do it.
Where's your pants?
Yeah, where's your pants, Guy Fury?
I didn't have time to draw my pants.
He wasn't so good.
I only knew that he wore a t-shirt.
I didn't know what the rest of it did.
No one ever sees the bottom.
He could be pantsless the whole time.
Oh, my goodness.
I feel sick as I see it.
yeah in flavor town you don't even need oh yeah you see the
digital circus over there wait wait wait but we're where
it's by the entrance
what's that on the right you guys think is that Minecraft
kind of oh no wait that's the jump buckets oh the jump
buckets from the SpongeBob all right I'll do SpongeBob next.
Bikini bottom.
I think that has to be a big map, right?
That has to be a big one.
But not too big.
Wait, I've already drew SpongeBob before.
Oh, man.
Patrick, Patrick.
You draw it again, draw it again, draw it again.
Be Patrick.
Wait, is it two hunters?
Because we could be SpongeBob and Patrick or Squidward or
Salke.
Oh, that's true.
That's so cute.
All right, download.
Subscribing?
I'm subscribing.
Subscribe, subscribe.
Okay, this is called.
Sponch Seekers.
Oh, hell, Ma.
Sponch Bob took 40 Benadryls.
What?
Do you guys know that one?
Nope.
That one's a little niche, maybe.
A little bit.
Me, me, niche.
All right, I'm ready.
Here, niche me, I'm in.
We've got this.
Yeah, we've got this.
We got this!
We got this, we got this!
Yeah, we got this!
We got this!
I'm gonna ruin your bromance and see if I can get it.
Go away!
No!
No, we're still us!
I was still us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who do you wanna be?
It's the pizza!
I'll be...
I don't remember the characters very well.
Oh, okay, I'll be Patrick.
I'm gonna be, I'll be SpongeBob.
It's like yellow on top, blue on the bottom.
How bad could it be, right?
Yeah, exactly.
You got this.
Wait, I'm Patrick.
Wait, I don't know if this is the right color.
yellow but never mind oh my god wait i can't see anything am
i being pink am i turning pink no wait wait what color what
color is are your shorts are they black or blue when is
there i think they're blue oh they're brown they're brown
they're brown oh jesus oh my gosh i don't know where to hide
this map is i didn't watch sponge bob growing up because my
brother liked it so thus i could not like it you know oh so
true good yeah all right color i don't trust myself but
that's okay that is not the color that that i think it
should be i have an idea i just look like i ship myself wait
i'm going green what do girls think wait wait i have an idea
this is this is not brown this is not even close to brown oh
my god i just have to make it i just have to make it over it
Girls, I got a bad feeling about this.
Oh boy.
I keep flicking.
When I'm there.
Spend some shit pants.
What?
Oh shoot, we have...
Okay, wait, what does Patrick's face look like, guys?
I don't know.
Oh shoot, what does his face look like?
I don't know why the color would not give me brown.
Oh no, the map.
version of SpongeBob.
I'm just committing now.
I'm Patrick.
I just realized they were way better places to hide.
Oh boy.
Oh yeah, look at us!
Oh, I'm still in.
Yeah, oh my god.
Oh wait, there are.
There might be.
Has anybody at my house?
I'm gonna go check.
Who's here?
Patrick's home.
Anybody walking around here?
Patrick's looking for you.
This is like Patrick ASMR.
Patrick ASMR role play.
Actually great, great idea.
Nobody is responding to me.
Wait, what the hell is going on?
There's like, no, this is Patrick.
There's like pipes and stuff.
What is all of this?
I can't respond.
be such a huge fraud.
I didn't watch SpongeBob, so I don't know what anybody says.
Live, you just have to be like, what's up, guy?
Oh, no, I know the narrator.
I know the narrator bit.
That's about it.
Patrick's looking.
Oh, he likes burgers.
Patrick.
What was that?
Oh, where was he?
He walked right past me.
He knew me was a burger on top of the burger crate and you
stepped on her.
I wasn't even done painting.
never worked here i'm sorry but i'm going this is patrick
what's wrong about patrick patrick's searching around and i
found plankton sponge boy be bob that's about all i know
seen somebody yet you haven't seen me yet if you haven't
seen snuffy yet mtw in santa rambo are you trying to be me
because that's like the worst that's the worst impression
i've ever heard in my entire life i'm just being you can i
get up can we get a squidward in here i'm getting too much
patrick energy in the call right now what's wrong with
patrick it's a species Okay, I would just like to say I
didn't get to see me, but you guys, my fellow hiders, you're
not even trying.
What is this?
Okay, I tried really hard.
Sorry for my language.
You're like protecting yourself from a freaking tornado.
Shut up.
Are you under a table?
I'm going to talk about your hiding spot.
Girl, I'm sick.
Okay, I'm sick.
You're sick in the head.
patrick that's you that's it i'm gonna see what you're
hiding huh yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna have to start talking
about your hiding spot i mean you're all ragging on each
other's hiding spots but nobody's been found yet yeah we
haven't found it found you guys oh what the i'm here for the
whimsy my spot was whimsical i liked your shelter in place
wait where was she he only understood
Nuffy's spot looks like she's like, it's like under her red.
It's not.
It's literally.
This is not even a spot.
I didn't know what to do.
Saboteur?
That song where the something was in my, oh my god, what
song was it where the guy was painting against the wall?
Like, what?
What?
It's just like, yeah, yeah.
Somebody that used to know that.
Somebody that used to know.
Somebody that I used to know.
Sorry, Limeu, I think I'm useless this map.
I feel...
No, you're great.
We're having a good time.
But Patrick, you're Patrick.
I'm Patrick.
Yeah, I'm enjoying the Patrick stuff, so...
Okay, I'll keep going.
Thank you.
I see a digital circus right next to us.
It's crazy that SpongeBob and the digital circus are set in
the same universe.
They are.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
SpongeBob is also set in place in Missouri.
SpongeBob?
SpongeBob's brain scan was from some random guy who works at
a minimum wage job.
That's why he's stuck in this eternal hell.
Wait, there is something weird up there.
What is up there?
You can see the amazing digital circuits from here.
Wait, where are you guys?
You can see the digital circuits.
Wait, what?
Why is SpongeBob mad?
Wait.
He's having one too many crabby patties.
Yeah.
Like, that's it, Mr. Crabs.
SpongeBob shit his pants, so he's upset.
Oh!
When I shit my pants.
I thought everyone was on my side.
But I went and blew it.
In my pants.
Now she won't even spare a passing glance.
Oh, just because I pooped my pants.
I'm big.
Larry.
Where are you getting this?
SpongeBob turned into a cloud And no girl ever wants to
change You two, turn around, look up Oh my god I was so, I
was looking I was looking You know I dropped down
accidentally That's horseshit, I can't get in there That's
a, that's a cheat We can't get in there It's not a cheat But
I'm not allowed in Oh, no, you have to crouch.
Yeah, you have to crouch.
Oh, I looked in there too.
I tried looking behind the door.
Very nice.
I'm sorry, I'm so small.
I didn't realize it was such an obstacle.
No, no, no, I thought it was just like a you're not allowed
in there, their spot.
But no, you have to kind of like wiggle your body in.
You do, it's annoying.
Wait, Nimmies is so good actually.
She looks just like a burger.
One angle.
It's been a nice thing to say to someone.
I'm gonna give you an A-on.
Aeon.
Oh wait, I need to Aeon Snuffy.
I have three seconds to Aeon Snuffy.
No Aeons.
I'm raking into Aeons.
Big Aeons.
I have all the Aeons.
What's the next map?
Next map.
We have Overwatch.
Where's Wally?
Lush Kays.
Mirage from Counter Strike.
The peak.
Oh my god.
Uh, Luigi's Magic.
Peaches Castle and Luigi's Mansion.
We have Luigi's Mansion.
Luigi's.
All right, do we want basic or infection for this one?
I don't know.
Basic, I think.
Because it's one seeing each other's hiding spots.
Basic is fun.
Yeah.
Two hunters, yeah.
Two hunters.
All right, I'm setting it up.
Now.
I can probably do like two more rounds because I have to be
awake in seven hours for the tension.
Oh, no.
Do we want to make this one LG then?
We could do one or two.
two we should make the next one I can do two more two more
this one and then a map that everyone really wants to do
okay okay yeah we can do play again next time this is fun
I'm so sorry I couldn't play for very long I have like so
much stuff going on this week I'm sorry you don't have to
apologize for that girl yeah I mean whatever whatever you're
recording that you can't tell us yeah I'm sorry but I'm so
sorry it's at 97% I know it's so cool I bet it's so cool.
It is.
Stop.
I bet it's like really cool.
Okay.
Matara, are you gonna download?
It's like 98.
That is the longest 97%.
I don't know why.
It's like it's keeping me at 98%.
Look, look, look.
I'm not lying.
Are you on dial up right now?
Thank you.
and tell your mom to stop calling on the phone to hang out
it's my roommate my roommate's streaming she's being a
streamer girl look he's hogging all the ram like we're
literally all streaming what's your no for real okay hold on
let me unsubscribe and then subscribe again sounds good
sounds good i'm just gonna unsubscribe from you and i won't
subscribe again Okay.
I'm going to unhit that notification bell.
That's good riddance.
I'm not going to like, I'm not going to subscribe.
I disliked.
Wait, while you're doing that, I'm going to get some milk
tea.
I was going to say water, but I'm going to get some milk
We're going to activate Lyme malicious when you say that.
I have to get out of my I have to get out of my cardboard
floor.
Hold on.
Okay.
It's actually, are you getting your aligners out?
tomorrow.
Yes.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
It's going to be.
Yay.
Thank you very much.
I'm excited, but he said it'd be an hour and a half because
he wants to like fix some things like the aligners like made
the top of my tooth kind of jagged.
So he's like, I'm going to just smooth it all out and do the
composite and then I'm going to take the buttons off.
And then I'm going to do this and then I'm going to do that.
I'm like, okay.
And he was like, okay, so an hour and a half.
I was like, oh my God, please no.
But okay.
people use when they talk about teeth yeah yeah i'm gonna
take your buttons off yeah yeah it's they put like they put
like composite material on the front of your teeth so that
the aligners can like attach better so for like a year even
when my aligners aren't off when i'm eating i think so it's
like they apply it directly to the surface of the teeth and
then it hardens and just attaches oh yeah it's like that's
hardcore yeah it's it's supposed to be subtle because it's
like teeth colored but obviously it just makes your teeth
look really knobbly because it's like you got bumps all over
your teeth so like this one time I met I met the I met the
boyfriend of a lady that I'd known for a while and he was
very polite to me and then afterwards apparently like when
they went home he said she was a nice girl but her teeth
were really weird the lady was like she's got aligners in
man her teeth aren't actually shaped like that oh my god
That's so weird.
It's insane to my face.
Lime Oof, it makes you feel better.
Weird teeth are my fetish.
Oh, oh, oh shit.
Oh no.
Okay.
Well, I'm gonna go mess up my teeth.
Yeah.
You can, you just go take it off yourself.
You know, you'll need a dentist for that.
You're beautiful with weird teeth.
Just start wrenching them off.
Thanks.
Like the cooking.
Is that what you wanted to be Patrick and you wanted her to
be SpongeBob?
Lime's never had weird teeth, though.
She always had very pretty teeth.
your teeth are very tired okay girls i don't know why it's
stuck at 99 play this one without me should we do a
different one yeah let's do a different one we do a
different one i don't know why like i even shared the
screenshots it like is 98 than 99 i'm sorry before started
where are we going tarah will be in here if we if she's on a
hat maybe she doesn't have a map downloaded maybe she can
get down those like 99 of the assets maybe i don't know why
it did that It literally stopped me at 99.
Oh, but now it put me in as killer.
So maybe I am in.
Yeah.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, wow.
This is actually a recreation.
This is literally from the GameCube game.
Yeah, what is this?
Oh, this is the Ouija's mansion.
The first one.
Yeah, the first Ouija's mansion.
Wait, oh, okay.
Wait, what?
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, wow.
It does not like something.
Oh, God.
It's like a new hunter because, uh, Matara can't load in.
Right, right.
We got it.
Oh.
It still shows that it's me.
That was freaky.
Oh my god.
Is Matara gonna be selected again?
Yeah, it's still supposed to be that it's me.
Oh gosh.
We're gonna be stuck in like a loop of time loop.
Uh oh.
Luigi's mentioned purgatory.
Wait, wait, wait.
We'll see if it reselects after.
Maybe I'll download.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna paint myself then.
Yeah, me too.
Yeah, I think we're fine now.
It's not what Luigi looks like.
Like one of your French women.
How'd you get the mustache so good?
I don't think his mustache looks like that though, does it?
But it's a great mustache.
No.
Oh my god, wait, this is actually great.
Oh wait.
I don't know where to hide.
I think that would be something very ambitious.
I think this is ingenious, personally.
You know that doesn't work either.
You can climb, but how do you lower yourself?
Control.
Oh, that makes sense, yeah.
That would be it.
Oh, my God, the little overalls.
Cute.
Is that a hat?
I'm going to see you wearing on your hat.
Yeah, it's my hat.
Yeah, good job.
Thank you.
This might work.
we'll see how it goes does that mean i have to be mario yeah
you should be mario mario
what's happening yeah oh he's doing it again it's doing it
again oh is it yeah no doing what it's the time oh wait oh
no no it's just time okay just kidding yeah it's just
they're about to i i screwed up oh dear i just might do you
remember how to switch around so i can see my other So I can
paint on the other side.
You can use the middle mouse button to rotate.
Thank you.
Oh, wait.
Do you see anything?
I'm like super zoomed in on the map.
And then we go up.
Do you still see it?
Like you got it?
Yeah.
I'm just kind of like slowly in.
It's kind of weird.
Dang it.
Whatever.
This is such a cool map.
It is.
It's very creative.
But it's okay.
Oh, you make a map then.
Be give it your bed.
I'm risking it all with mine.
I got very, I got very, like, indecisive about where I
wanted to be.
Yeah.
Oh, Doki's, yours is good.
Yours is, oh, well, kind of.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just realized.
Oh, Snuffy, yours is, oh.
It was good.
It was really good.
How about this?
It was good.
Oh.
I thought you did a double take.
I was about to run, too.
Limeo, I think you might be good.
Yeah.
Every time Miss says, like, we have time.
I know.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Don't believe her.
Don't believe her lies.
I don't even know.
I know, like, it's...
I see you.
Oh, are you dead?
Oh, wait.
I lied?
I lied.
He's been sabotaging you guys.
He's like, Mint, don't look at my hiding place, please.
I'm sorry, I didn't know.
I think Mint's hiding place is really good too, guys.
I'm sorry.
I said your spots were good.
I think we haven't seen her yet because we haven't like
haven't heard on the I didn't hear anything downstairs.
I don't even know how you get into this room.
I didn't even know these rooms existed.
That's crazy.
Yeah, sometimes you do stuff.
You're like, wait a second, there was a whole other room.
I love how the shadows and shading are just like, oh, wait,
I'm stuck.
You just gotta find whatever room they are in.
Either of them.
Wait, either of them.
Yeah, it's not even on Doki Mint.
Wait, what?
What?
Are you saying you're in the main room?
I don't know what I'm saying!
I'm sick!
Of course, Mint lives after fucking all of us.
Why are you trying to...
Why are you...
I'm just a hater.
Why are you a hater?
No, I don't know.
Every time you say, wow.
That's a good hiding spot.
We fucking die.
There's no way.
I was trying to compliment you guys.
You were very sweet.
I appreciated the compliment as I swatted my brains all over
the ceiling.
Yeah.
Me too.
It helped me find you.
I'm praying.
Yeah, I'm praying on her downfall.
Why am I being targeted?
Wait, there's going to be a whistle in eight seconds.
Yeah, yeah.
Give me a whistle.
Woohoo.
Hello, beautiful.
Hello.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, I don't know if she's in here.
She might be in the wall.
I don't think she's in here because we haven't seen the
score go up.
Oh, there must be like another way to get to that room.
No, I think it's bugged, actually.
If you never see the score go up, it must be so like well
hidden.
It's like kind of tucked away.
You haven't seen her yet because, yeah, the score doesn't go
up.
Oh, is it actually like a CC thing?
Where could she be?
Oh, where could she be?
We get in real time, but the seekers have to, like, update,
like, every couple of seconds.
Oh, I see.
Now there's a little Minto.
You hear her.
I heard the whistle.
Where could she be?
Whoa, what's through the window?
What is that?
I don't know.
Probably the amazing digital circus.
Wait, can we go outside?
It has this other digital circus.
Where is she?
Oh, we got points.
We saw her.
There's no way.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, but Minto's just...
she's a ghost she's actually just a theater yeah she's just
a wiji from beyond the gray
i'm glad matthias what oh she's behind the fridge i even
went back here oh my god you got snuffy or no that is a
crazy hiding spot yeah snuffy was like snuffy is so good
that is so how did you see that i was I was staring right at
it.
I didn't make it believable enough.
I glanced past it.
It's only because I came back for a second look.
I got an Aeon.
Yeah, because I believed in yours.
I appreciate that.
It won't let me like snuffies though.
Oh, you can only like one person.
Only one person.
Still snuffies Aeon.
Sorry.
I already give snuffie aeon.
Aeon.
I'm blowing up on mecha chameleon.
Holy crap.
Yay.
Okay.
Is this our last one then?
Yeah.
Last one.
This is our last one.
Last LG.
All right, guys.
I'm going to let's talk about that.
Doki, have you been the Hunter like at all?
I know, right?
I've done Hunter like two times.
I could do it a third time.
Yeah, do it.
I'm ready.
I sent in two to Hunter.
All right.
There's Wurz Wally, Overwatch, Li Zhang, Lush Caves, CSGO,
Mirage.
Peak Airport I think Overwatch could be fun Chat which one
should we play?
Which one does chat want to see?
Overwatch you're going to give me an advantage.
I feel like actually where's Wally could be crazy because of
the amount of stripes.
I actually want to see how that works out.
I think we should do where's Wally.
Are we all going to be Wally?
Everything's just going to be fucking red and white stripes
everywhere.
Two or one?
Hunters or one for the last one?
Oh two.
Two, two Hunters.
yeah yeah i'm basically useless i'm so tired until your wait
time all right click okay time the good thing about being
sick is then you don't get sick again for a while it's true
that is it true is that true we're now going into blonde
season and i literally your immune system becomes vulnerable
and you be get susceptible to more disease this map doesn't
look like a lot of stripes I'm gonna be honest.
Yeah, I was gonna say that did not look very weird as well.
Wait, this looks like dukey, actually.
Are we sure we get to this?
This is a Roblox obstacle course.
Are we sure we want to do this one?
We only got a preview when we click download.
This will be LG.
If this is a shit map, the next map will be LG.
Fair enough.
And then it hits 5 a.m.
Like, LG, LG.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think, okay.
This one, you guys, this one I think is really messed up.
I think you're literally supposed to, like, put yourself on
the portraits.
I think so.
It's just pictures.
It'll be an exercise in art.
What?
It's going to be a...
You're actually playing Warriors on.
Oh, never mind.
I'm a hunter.
All right, let's go.
Warriors on.
Oh, boy.
You guys are like, I'm really excited about it.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I just fell off the map, you guys.
Wait.
Oh, I just fell like a...
Oh, okay.
Do I come back?
Yeah, you come back.
You're coming back.
This is a Roblox obstacle.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, oh my God.
You guys selected Wally.
Wait, guys.
I just might have found the other before you picked.
I might have found an awesome spot.
Wait, how do you even get to the posters?
I know, you really can't.
Are you, it's too big.
This map is too big.
what is this you have to like make a leap of faith i know
it's actually kind of terrible
uh wait i gotta wait there's a wall you can't even get to
them what is what is this i don't know it's just for those
who like the theme of waldo maybe yeah i just wanted to look
at him you know yeah yeah look at waldo are you supposed to
just play the game with friends and you also know that the
the map was made by someone british because yeah it's wally
yeah who the hell is wally i was like my people my people
where's wally waldo is wally here dude this is insane
i think mother doing a face dokey i just went full like red
and white stripes it's an attempt you know I'm really tired
I've lived like for a while I don't know Whoa Oh Matara ears
is pretty good Oh no wait I shouldn't say that I don't know
Yeah The mint compliment curse I'm so sorry Oh god What the
hell is wrong with you guys Oh my god What do you
I don't know if any of us are on the painting because it's
impossible to get over there.
Yeah.
I got stuck.
Well, I guess I could have, you know, I don't know.
Damn, Mimi, you are crazy.
I think they're going to see me though.
I wonder if you guys are hiding.
You're not even on the painting, right?
No.
Oh, she might be.
Don't say that.
She might be.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I muted an off angle from over here if you see it.
It offset you.
Oh my gosh, Mint.
What are you doing?
They're never going to find you.
I got stuck here.
That is impossible.
I was trying to go to...
clipping mint is no clipped to the world oh i was trying to
get to a painting and i got stuck wait i can't even find her
hold on hold on yeah go to the go through the no no no okay
don't tell me all right all right go ahead do your best i
don't think this is a serious competitive map if that helps
all right this is roblox what are you talking about oh oh oh
all right so mint is stuck That's the only hint and she's
near a painting so that's all we need to know.
I'm stuck by a painting.
She's stuck by a painting.
That's all the hints we get.
Somebody is cheesy.
Oh, I felled off.
I just saw your little nameplate go flying through the
world.
Oh,
damn.
Did I see it?
Tactical.
Wait, did you?
These are great.
Oh yes, yes, good.
These are really good.
I'm very happy.
No, he's playing serious, playing to win.
This is all I can do.
No, it's not.
You can do much more.
I call this the trout technique.
Oh, I need a whistle somewhere.
Don't fall off the world.
Don't fall off the world, Doki Bird.
I can't, there's an invisible while you're oh that's where i
fell first did you just fall off again
hey excuse me my partner keeps like throwing herself off the
map i need to go back to snuffy because it's like crazy no
clipping i'm not is the is the tv the television oh yeah do
you want to
not all channels turn turn on the tv any channel oh they're
gonna get her stop no you have that faith in stuff there's
no way i i don't have faith in mint because you're gonna
keep oh my god it's because you're gonna keep snake wow
great spot and then they're gonna find her when you say why
does like the giant waldo sign say where's waldo at home
see a bunch of like really messed up like items that he
decided not to put on the map just floating in the skybox
over there oh we have another digital circus oh yeah this is
waldo at home at the very bottom oh my god i'm back in the
hunter screen that's kind of crazy what i'm exploring you'll
like get you then no no no i'm where i'm i'm free cameraing
and i'm just oh yeah this map is big enough that i can't
really hear where the whistle's coming from like i heard it
vaguely it was like near me for a second but that for but
then i fell off the map so i didn't know where the
positioning was again i i lost control of my oh my god
snuffy be careful snuffy be careful how do you feel right
now mint how do you feel are you feeling the pressure as if
there's a weight on you oh that's good no that's good
No!
It's the weight of the pressure.
Did you just sabotage?
Yeah, the weight of the pressure.
Oh, I'm off the map.
I watched it drop.
So dope.
I don't know where I'm at.
Oh, man.
I could not get up anymore for some reason.
Welcome to Stocksville.
Yeah.
I don't know.
like actually gotten stuck i can't climb this i don't know
why yeah welcome can i jump to here hell yeah parkour oh my
computer's crashing oh gosh okay where was she right come
here i fell inside the little the little thingies trying to
get to the painting i fell in there i know yeah we weren't
getting that Yeah.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Snuffy, you were MVP.
Yeah, Snuffy was my crazy move.
I had to keep myself occupied somehow.
This was like...
Were you just rotating or something?
The Waldo world.
She was.
Whenever you guys would come around, she's rotate to the
other side.
Yeah, she would.
She just rotated.
Get rotated.
I lost my sanity in the world.
in the Where's Wally World?
That's my t-shirt.
I should have wrote that on my little guy.
I think we do one more LG because that map was pissed.
Okay.
Yeah.
One final truth, LG.
Can we just do one of the base maps?
Yeah, those tend to be pretty good.
They tend to be more balanced, I feel like.
All right, the hide and seek mansion, sewers, the back
rooms, indoor country, penguin hotels, Sugar Land, or Osaka?
Did we do indoor country?
What is that?
that was the farm one yeah the farm one yeah yeah i don't
mind yeah i'm good with any we could do random if we do
random it'll pick the one the dlc oh it'll like where's
waldo again don't pick the amazing digital circus again oh
no please oh i got the digital circus all right indoor
country i started we want to look at me you guys i'm i'm i'm
we can all get inside Let's make it random.
Let's make it random.
Make it random.
I'll stay out of it because I was at a secret already.
Okay.
Fair, fair, fair.
Oh my gosh, your cars!
It was nothing.
I tried to be late.
It was too late.
Whoa.
Me and Mint, let's go!
Yeah!
Hell yeah.
Mataminto!
Oh, this is, this was my trauma.
Thank you.
What the fuck?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You write H-A and I write G-S.
H-O.
This has the same energy as like a T-T-I-C.
Hold on, do we have to set?
A T-T-I-C.
I'm gonna write Attic.
Okay, never mind, hold on.
No, I wrote ha.
Okay, okay, hold on.
I'll do it in my colors.
How do I?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I'll write ha in the front as well.
Okay, yeah, okay, good, good, good, good.
And I'll write ha at the top of my head.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you guys hags?
Are you?
Yeah.
You will join us one day.
Okay.
I'll write ha on my shoulders as well.
Well, Doki, if you never join us in hagnum, that means
you're not good.
That means you're not good?
What does that mean?
That means, uh, yeah, exactly.
Oh, yeah.
I thought you meant like a skill issue like you're not good.
Oh,
and a big butt.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Make a big butt for you too.
Oh, I can't, how do I zoom?
I gotta zoom out.
It just looked okay, but I think actually this was a mistake
long term.
the game or the the no no the one i've chosen here me too
honestly me too same same i believe i was like yeah this is
gonna be good oh no oh no oh dear let's go
you the rub rabbits over there jesus are you hating are you
hating no no of course not i i fucking love the rub rabbits
i love them they're great too are we rub rub rabbits it's
like the sega property where you do like a sequence of like
absolutely fucking insane mini games while that does like
this really ridiculous penis music soundtrack and are you
calling her singing penis music like come on i would never
do that no feast no thinking i i broke under pressure i
didn't know where to go sometimes hiding in plain sight is
the best thing to do agreed especially when i'm sick as a
dog and i can't you are just a dog
stuffy's really good that's a really good spot is she moving
is she oh i'm gonna go look for snuffy
sorry it's great they'll never know
Oh Serves you right.
This is where I was before I crashed.
Okay, so there's one of them here.
I got a folk.
Oh my god.
I can't see anything They all started looking up my strats
stopped working.
Yeah Everybody started looking up Snuffy, how funny are you?
She's hilarious.
I will say it's pretty funny.
Yeah?
It's pretty funny.
Wait, did these get knocked over?
I liked your hiding spot, Nimi.
Oh, that was good.
They were already knocked over.
I know.
I asked the same stuff.
I would say somebody that I used to know, but I didn't know.
Oh, shoot.
I'm stuck.
Did Snuffy?
Do you see?
My Snuffy!
No!
Oh, I can't.
It won't let me get up.
Don't worry.
You guys will see.
Oh, we'll see Snuffy.
Um, Matara, I'm only able to crawl.
It's all up to you.
Did the game crash?
Okay.
Can you press crouch?
Press climb or crouch or something?
Yeah, I did.
It says I don't have enough space to get up.
Wait.
i think if you like crawl more you'll be able to see it
that's okay for my funny oh no they just saw your spot we're
like take my game seriously here i like i keep hearing it i
keep hearing something okay i'm oh wait are you under here
no you're not under here wait what was your spot then snuffy
it was wait you guys can still see me No, it's gone.
It's gone.
When the game ends, you'll see it because it'll still have a
record.
Oh, okay, good.
Yeah, I want to see it.
There's like somebody here, but I'm so like, I'm getting so
congested.
I can't.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
You guys see me on the ceiling perfectly.
Because ceiling tactics are old news.
Yeah, they are.
They are.
You got to get with the times, man.
This is new strat.
New strat.
I don't care of the server anymore.
Oh no!
No!
I just...
Okay, okay, it's like here.
I heard the...
Whew!
Oh my god!
Where?
No, that was really good!
Literally under you!
No, no, no, no, no, look!
Wait, I'm stuck.
Oh my god!
Wow!
That was good!
was never gonna godly gaming i was never wow the only thing
that gave you away is that it kept like whooing so i was
like okay yeah yeah oh the other one is like over here is it
here oh i thought i heard the whole like this way do it
again woo-hoo for me woo-hoo for me girl oh oh no way i
didn't see before that's right.
Oh my god.
I couldn't get out of the wall.
Wait, I have enough?
Where was Snuffy?
It's right here.
Left side.
Oh, you don't have the record anymore.
No.
It's on one of those.
It's the horses.
It was very good.
Yeah, it was really cool.
We'll send a screenshot.
Wait, wait.
Someone can send a screenshot of it.
She gave the horse an extra leg.
Oh, I wasn't gonna say if it's a little pee-pee-poo-poo kind
funny but it looks like my whole steam like died oh oh my
god you got back i knew you were hacking i knew you were
hacking you got back then yeah what the heck oh man i'm so
bummed what an anti-climatic end i would make you guys laugh
so bad bad don't worry we laugh i laugh and i i thought we
got to see it we got to see it yeah Nothing in my heart.
I'm nothing in my heart.
Wait, wait, wait.
Someone can screenshot.
Wait, Stuffy screenshots from your bot.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, let me dig that up really quick.
Yeah, you guys have to see it.
It was crazy that I did not realize she was last that long.
To be fair, also, I do not know how, but you guys also
walked around me so much, and I'm just going to say that was
good enough.
I was even looking at the horses so much.
I don't know.
Maybe nothing looked...
That was just normal.
Yeah.
They just, you know, I once, well, actually, maybe I
shouldn't say this story.
Wait, wait, wait, what?
I'm so curious, man.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so curious.
It was like one of those like outback restaurants that have,
it had like a little bowl outside of it.
And I would always, it was like anatomically correct bowl.
And I would look at it and I'd be like, wow, they really
made it so, uh, I don't know.
Is that correct?
I don't know.
Does it?
Wow.
Wait, they had a what outside of it?
It was like a bull statue, but they made it really like.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
We had big bulls, you know?
I see.
This is my beautiful masterpiece.
Oh my gosh, that angle.
Wait, what?
I would have never seen that.
Honestly, it looks like a tail.
It looks a bit like a tail.
Wait, so do you have the front side?
Front tail?
Yeah, let me get the front side.
Oh, those are the teeth.
I mean, sorry, not the feet.
Sorry, not the feet.
Sorry.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Clarify.
When you were calling the bull an atomically correct bull.
Yeah, what?
What are you looking at?
I didn't mean to say that.
Teeth?
I didn't mean to say the T.
Hey, I'm not judging.
I'm just saying.
I don't even know if I can show this on stream, but I did
anyway.
I showed it on.
I mean, it was on screen.
It was on the screen, man.
It was on the screen.
Wait, I'll show the bit.
I'll show the one that is stuck.
This is a disgusting angle.
It looks like a tail though from the back.
Sometimes you girls invented these angles like Doki on the
chum bucket was crazy.
Yeah.
I even fell down from the jack fell down from the hat.
Yeah, you have to go back up.
I was like, oh shit.
There he is.
There she is.
I want to know how long she would have lasted too.
I can't believe my whole I know you're gonna whistle like
that looking like that.
I think Steam might be having problems because I just got a
cloud error as soon as I exited the game.
So I think there's some stuff going on.
Wait, we all got VAC banned for...
Oh no.
Broadcasting our degeneracy.
Maybe one of these maps I downloaded just, or malware
actually.
I downloaded like 20 maps.
That Where's Waldo World was actually like a trivia horse
dude.
terrible if we could actually get on the painting that would
have been fun i know we're all trying to get to the
paintings yeah we literally planned around steve maintenance
chat isn't it ironic that did they delay it just to impact
the sloppy oh no no i think i think there's an error or
something they're like they're pushing this stream we'll
push our steam maintenance oh they heard us having Yeah,
let's knock them offline.
It'll be funny.
But thank you very much for inviting me, you guys.
I had fun.
I'm sorry I'm still sleeping for this one, but can we do it
again when I'm awake?
Yes!
Let's do it again.
We'll get a bigger group, and then we can replay Digital
Circus.
No.
Not there.
We're going to have to actually look up some good math.
I'm going to abstract.
Yeah, I'm down to do another collab of this game.
yeah that was really cool to get it that was really silly
yes Bye-bye.
E-bye.
E-ye.
Good night.
Bye-bye.
Feel better.
Thank you.
I'm going to do the thing for you real soon.
I promise.
I'm going to do it with this voice.
Because I can't keep delaying on you.
I know your life, so don't worry.
I'm not going to say anything.
I also don't know what you're talking about.
Oh, wait.
I owe you something.
Yes, you.
And it's not money.
Oh, yes, you do owe me.
I also send me also the thing that you need to send me.
Yeah, yeah.
I got to come to see.
Girl, I hope you're free tomorrow because I really need you,
but I've been sick.
Oh, tomorrow probably.
Yeah, we'll make time.
How are you?
How was your day?
Sorry, now that I have you to myself, I'm going to steal
you.
I'm stealing her for five minutes.
How's the sneaky closet?
How are you?
It's, um, it's coming along.
I, I kind of destroyed my...
What the thing I gave you in the closet?
I did.
I put it in my closet.
It smells so good.
Tara gave me a, uh, a smell, a smelly, a smelly tag.
It's like a freshener for the, for literally your clothing.
Yes.
A freshener for your clothing.
And it smells so good.
You could put it.
You guys, I'm so happy.
happy sorry go on no that's it it was good um i i have been
just getting things in the mail like constantly yeah yeah
you're about to get something else in the mail what me no
i'm kidding but i did
no but i actually did send you something wait what you don't
know my address you're gonna see what i do i asked for
manager what but but but in in in in his defense i was like
this is what I'm going to send if you you know like he
doesn't know my address I didn't give him my new address oh
well where am I sending this then I don't know oh I better
figure it out wait did you already send it uh let me double
check hold on I'll check out I've been I've been honestly
like in bed I'm so out of it do I sound a little congested
uh just a little bit nice nice okay i'm gonna let you with
the wisps okay okay have fun i love you love you my you're
not even on your stream oh because potato pc yeah because my
potato pc is on fire i am on your stream hi okay bye bye bye
bye get off my screen bye thank you guys for watching this
was so fun sorry i was late um the thing that I was doing
you'll know sooner rather than later so cool things ahead
yeah sorry that there was a little bit of scuff and
everything and I just kind of like started stream and
everything and I was for the thing that I was doing they
were like oh yeah it'll be like a half hour and I was like
okay cool I could do a half hour.
Ended up being two hours.
So, very cool.
That's okay.
It is cool.
I'm not upset at them, obviously.
I'm not upset at all, even.
I had fun playing, playing on a Mecca chameleon.
So I'm going to do this for you guys.
Hold on, watch this.
Watch this.
I still don't know the controls of this dang game.
Oh, there we go.
Bye!
Oh, also, hold on, wait, I want to do this too.
I want to do this too.
Why is there no music in this?
Oh, I can barely see you guys.
On the face only a mother could love.
Oh, no, no, no, we're supposed to be blue.
We're supposed to be blue.
It's you!
so much as you guys thank you anatomical bowls and teeth
feet my brain is absolutely cooked today ah thank you guys
thank you thanks for shorter stream i had so much fun
bye bye bye bye bye see you oh now there's music Do, do, do,
do.
Hey.
Sorry, I just realized I didn't have time to put the lizards
again because I was so busy before streaming.
I'm really sorry.
But I will have lizards next time.
For sure.
For sure, lizards.
Lizards incoming.
Lizards coming.
Lizards, hot lizards near you.
Lizards.
Lizards on the way.
Bye.